[Music]
welcome to aftermarket we'll be talking
about
whatever we want today we got kelly with
us today
she is a producer you do shows
uh reality shows right what kind of what
kind of shows have you done
just one well i've only done one reality
show uh bling empire on netflix
she's also in the show casey not just
producing it
in the show i'm sorry i watched jack get
it right man
i didn't know there's that many balling
asians in l.a
oh there's more there's more there's
more there's a sequel
list their names go oh i like that i
heard of a secret
that like the people so there's actually
way richer people but they don't want to
be known and then
the people that are like they're pretty
damn rich already but they're just like
i'll be i'll put myself out there but
the super rich are just like don't even
put me on forbes
depends it depends really okay because
i'm not even in that circle so it's all
rumors for me
or he secretly is and he's just not
telling you no he's definitely not don't
worry
about himself you're rich or poor some
people do like the fame and some people
don't like the fame right so
so there's some people that like i've
heard pay to get in forbes
but they want to get him forbes to be in
the clout and to be able to be in that
circle
and i'm sure just as much as people that
are paid to be out of it because i don't
even want it
i paid to be in forbes and still didn't
make it no he was informed
oh [ __ ] yeah that's true that's true
but yeah how did you get into uh
producing and and show biz and
entertainment
i think it was just random i i started
producing scripted mostly scripted tv
and films about two years ago and then
uh
like the award-winning danger boys uh
show right dude that that was so good
you're welcome it's so good no you guys
so she was actually helping us produce
it and
it was just like the worst timing ever
we're really excited about the project
we shot it we had pitch materials photos
a one page
a pilot shot and then literally i think
we went out and we got some interest and
then kova hit and then all the
productions
yeah they're like pull the plug on
everything and we gotta do this again
but i also have to say kelly shout outs
to you because you were the first
producer that we felt like you kept
fighting for us
kept trying to look for people so you
were actively
you know like a lot of people talk in
the industry and then they don't really
do anything behind the scenes they don't
follow up
but for you you we just kept seeing that
you kept like
more activity whatever and we're getting
updated and we're just like yo she's
really got her backs
so that was awesome you know why why
does i want to be a member of the danger
voice
and final memory my intention yeah i
have to work with the title
i like it wow we should we should have
like one that's like
more current to the times and we want to
be more gender neutral
and whatever so then danger boys goes
like we need to recruit
no one wants to join cause danger people
danger peoples
yeah and then we bring in kids those
guys wouldn't do that that's what's
great about it
but she ends up running everything at
the end that's that's what the twist is
yeah i'm about to take your job oh true
it was the mastermind they're like oh
she has way better ideas than joe
calling him the mastermind that's the
roughest part you have to watch the show
yeah you gotta watch it but literally
when i was watching the pilot i was
laughing
so hard so hard and i watched it
probably five times a little guilty
thank you how did you get involved with
uh bling empire like when you
produce it like did you start from
scratch with like an idea and you had to
pitch
with a pilot too did you have to shoot
anything else yourself yeah no it was
such a long process in 2013 was when i
read the book crazy asians and that's
when nina jacobson and brad simpson
bought the rights for the book to be a
movie and when i read the book i was
like oh my god these are all like
fictional characters my friends
so i started developing the show but it
took forever i mean hollywood you guys
know it takes a while to get them to
really invest
in you know all asian cast show but i
think also because crazy creation is so
well
it helped us pave the way for this show
and
hopefully with glee empire we can pave
the way for more asian
that's true because there's what like
two or three reality tv shows about rich
asians right
there's two so there was house of halls
house of hall hbo and us
oh okay i like that you didn't have to
use asian in the title either you're
just like this is what it is asian bling
empire not a good ring but like bling
empire
sucks that's good that's universal i
would have called it bling a knees
empire
that's pretty good that's pretty good
it might be a little spin-off
was there are all the people in i don't
know if you could talk about this but
all the people in the show are they
friends or they know each other before
or you just
brought characters that were gonna like
majority of us were friends i've known
kane for like probably
eight or nine years i know christine for
over 10 years and then like
the newer friends were kevin um
was living the east coast that time when
when when i saw him and i was a sexy
model guy
to him yeah i kind of recruited him um
but even before with the camera start
rolling we were all gonna hang out
we all hung out for over a year together
what gives you the idea for this though
like
the book for your decisions so you just
like this is i can see this going so
many different places yeah because i'm
like these are like
like fictional characters my friends and
my circle friends so start putting it
together
yeah but but what you were saying
earlier is about when really rich people
they don't want to be on camera
that was the hardest thing you know
getting king's parents giving us
their blessing and all that stuff that
was hard yeah was that like the biggest
hurdle
trying to get the the green light from
the parents rather than like
because they don't want their stuff out
there you know like you know asian
culture have you convinced them uh
you know how much money you have now you
have this much more money
by saying that i'll be in as well oh
something like well if kelly's gonna do
it she's not gonna screw up her like you
know her reputation what do you think it
is about
our culture really that we i love to
watch rich people do [ __ ] i don't know
why
but i love it that's even though like
american for sure
like yeah it seems like we kind of we
gravitated yeah we dream about it but
like
i know like i just watched this
documentary about um in germany
it's the opposite rich people don't want
to be known and they don't
yeah it's different the culture is just
like yeah keep it secret
yeah i think people want to watch it
because it's part of it's something that
they they don't normally get to see
right but also i think empire was really
unique because you were able to see like
real life problems you know you talk
about facilities relationship problems
finding real parents so i think that's
why the show is so unique and everybody
was so vulnerable on the show
you know it's relatable yeah the the
older lady her titty popped out oh yeah
did you like that no i wasn't expecting
that i wasn't i was like
i thought it was a reality tv show i
didn't know i was like uh like a i don't
know
like a soft core porno like yeah
personal reality dude you're crazy
sometimes yeah titties do pop out huh
what kind of rating is that
nc 17 or what is that i don't think
netflix raised
oh really yeah uh what about a penis
palm check that penis pump
did you miss the apostles i might have
missed that one no i should watch that
yeah let's watch that one yeah that was
crazy did you guys watch it where the
titty popped out of the
of the what was the contrast of a titty
popping out she was just shopping and
she just
just changed it like she just decided to
change this i've never seen like a full
episode it's always been like clips and
stuff
yeah yeah i just wanted to support the
truth
she watched the entire episode he's like
i love how you went to bat first is so
sick
i i i only watched a couple ads for you
guys yeah
i watched clips on instagram it's my
favorite
i'm taking his job
everyone wants to know this right when
you're doing reality tv everyone goes
how much of it's manufactured how much
of it's like
fake or real it's pretty real it's
pretty real
yeah are you guys ever like i've to mind
the drama because we always think that
like when i watch kardashians i'm like
they had to mind drama for this yeah
i think we're i think everybody was
pretty real i mean the penis pump people
always thought that was planted
that was not planted you know so
interesting yeah
the fertility storyline i mean that was
pretty real you can't really
fake that one so that was shocking when
he came
when gabe came out i was shocked when he
said it was his problem the whole time
so he couldn't get right they couldn't
get pregnant he owned that it was
because of him
it was him and for 10 years she was
taking the hit from the family because
he's from the air of the sun dynasty
so like multi-generational money
oh you mean like the actual song dynasty
like the one we read in the history
books like they could trace the
bloodline
joe you can't talk anymore just
go watch it and come back fine i'm sorry
but i did see the clip when you guys
well not you but then you know they were
in the pool and
okay never mind he's not on tick tock it
was four seconds long
[Laughter]
just kidding i know i know kelly from a
different means
we work together on march that's how
i had no idea you were like producing
and doing all this stuff behind the
scenes
and then like she worked with one of my
childhood friends
uh which is another crazy rich asian but
um
i didn't know that like the whole
network of like
business crazy rich asians existed in la
i thought that was like a fable yeah
yeah this episode is brought to you by
hello
tushy and you know what's extremely
life-changing
it's extremely life-changing when i used
a bidet for the first time when was your
first
i believe it was when i was in japan
and i was like what how come this is on
every single public toilet
and i felt the cleanest my butt has ever
felt on any vacation
and i come back to the states i'm gonna
get one for sure and then i look i'm
like oh my goodness
this is really expensive and i wanted to
get one for every single bathroom but
i'm like nah
no way jose too expensive and that's why
i really like hello tishi
because now they're making it affordable
so that
everyone can have one and experience
what it feels like to have a fresh
clean butt after you poop especially
because it's so expensive it could like
end up costing thousands yeah and if
you're trying to hook up your whole
office with it
man we know it's expansive very
expensive yeah but actually i own a
tushy
at home and what's cool about it is it's
easy to install
it's super affordable it's stylish it's
eco-friendly
and it doesn't take any electricity or
anything like that it just uses the
flow of the water of the own mechanism
of the toilet to do the duty for you
yeah one of the things that's my
favorite thing about it is that it
actually cleans itself
so it's just a all-in-one package that's
so easy to use doesn't require
additional electricity plumbing
and it cleans itself and it's so
freaking awesome because that whole
system
on your toilet it has a 60-day
money-back guarantee
so if you try it and you don't like it i
don't know why you wouldn't like it you
can send it back and
the actual system is a 12 month warranty
too
and if you're like me and you already
got a tushy pop why don't you just
upgrade to a 3.0 model well
i don't know tushy maybe because your
product's so dang good it never broke on
me and i never had to use the 12 month
warranty but i do like it so i think i'm
gonna get
the 3.0 so if you want to know what we
butt ballers feel like go to off the
record to get 10
off plus free shipping and you're gonna
have the clean nice smooth butthole
and if your boyfriend or girlfriend
loves eating your ass they're gonna
thank you
so go to hellotushy.com off the record
for 10
off plus free shipping thank you hello
tishi like in the movie
crazy retractations the crossover danger
boys ex-splitting empire
oh yeah like crazy poor asians and crazy
rich
and it's all about how you're gonna try
to rob the [ __ ] yeah
yeah they're trying to like befriend
them and stuff that's good i think
there's something to it i was thinking
like
you know like one person hired the
danger boys because they're gang
and then they try to go through
something else that's a good one too
it's good
they become muscle and they get
backfired because dangerous are
dumb to be honest i will never hire you
guys
i'll give it i'll give it to my enemies
what would you hire them to do
the danger strip okay i'm good at it
yeah that's one thing we're kind of good
at doing kind of
the keyboard kind of yeah he was pretty
good at it yeah you were pretty good
i was too shy
[Laughter]
when you're doing something he's like
memory
when you're doing something in the
shadow of crazy origins where everyone's
talking about how like everyone's
talking about asians in hollywood right
now especially shane cheese coming out
oh i'm so excited and then right but
then you're doing something on netflix
and it's like an asian driven show
as well do you ever feel this pressure
i've heard about this pressure where
it's like i am the first cause not a lot
of people in hollywood have done this
before where like they're stewarding
like a bunch of asian stuff
where you're like i have this crazy
added pressure of i'm representing a
bunch of people
who have felt underrepresented
absolutely because
you know like at the beginning the show
has always been hey if we're going to do
this
we have to go all out everybody have to
be have to be vulnerable have to be
willing to put it on
out there otherwise let's not do it
because we don't want to screw this up
you know um we want to same thing with
you know crazy
crazy rich asians like they know they
had the pressure to have to do it right
so yeah for sure and season two is
bigger even bigger pressure
is it fair that you have to deal with
that or is it just is
i don't know if it's i mean i i can't
say it's not fair because for i'm i'm
grateful for the opportunity i'm
grateful that you know
it's doing so well did you grow up in
l.a uh i was born in china in chicago
oh cool boss in singapore when did you
come to l.a
when i come to l.a uh 21 so 14 years ago
i had to do my math i was like how old
am i okay yeah 14 years ago
oh but do you feel like you're a la
native
yeah yeah above ten years ago you become
uh angelino then after like 30 years
you're like i need to find another home
after paying taxes for that long yeah
you go florida texas nevada which one
49 other choices
are better no matter where i go i can't
tell where i came from or they'll be mad
they'll beat me up maybe you gotta get
your state plates before
you drive into town
that's great i was uh one of the
characters on the show um
i was like man like that world of just
because there's i think what people
think of rich people is your rich friend
that you grew up
with right like the rich person on the
street or whatever on your on your
street
uh but i think the rich people that were
in the show those are like the real rich
people like the people that are like oh
it's my birthday
um who wants to have lunch in paris like
that's like that's real rich to me i
thought rich was someone who made a
hundred thousand dollars a year
yeah yeah yeah but then these people i'm
like holy [ __ ] and then there's that a
girl on the show
i i was just like man this is her world
because i think she was like um
oh yeah i need to buy a couple pairs of
shoes how much that's gonna cost me
like twelve thousand i'm like what the
[ __ ] like every pair of shoes
is a thousand dollars in her brain you
know versus for me i'm like
you know vans are probably like 50 or 60
bucks yeah but like
when you're in that world do you does
everything
like everything that's like if a dinner
is under
500 bucks is it considered cheap i
already used that's pretty cheap
it's high that's [ __ ] tired under 500
females are you like god damn
yeah well what's that fila shoes what is
that cheap shoes
exactly exactly exactly that's all you
need to know exactly f-i-l-a that's
[ __ ]
dumb it was popular in the night do you
not know
have you heard of toms i actually heard
of tom okay
that actually i actually heard it casey
i buy like 30 of them i have no idea how
much they are but
yeah so what's what's because for me
like i feel ballin when i go into
like a restaurant i look at the menu
everything's under twenty dollars
yeah whatever you want baby
milkshakes i got it for you what
what's the number in the menu where
you're like oh this is whatever i can
order whatever i don't have to look at
the price
i don't know about me but like when
you're not even looking at the price
anymore
oh you just walk into places and they
don't have the price
gankstars yeah yeah yeah it's all
marketable ever look at prices then
sometimes i'm a little bit different
because i'm an entrepreneur i made my
money so it's a little bit different she
wasn't born rich
yeah so it's a little bit different with
you know some our cast members who are
born into money right
and they don't never look at the menu i
don't think so i mean funny thing
you mentioned um anna flew me for my
birthday to paris you know as a surprise
one of the things that they cut out that
was really freaking cold that as a
surprise
she shut down the palace of her side
what the [ __ ]
i love the palace of her side you had
that private before
i ran around the holy why why would they
not put that in the show why are you
in this room with them yeah yeah all
right she's down to earth
because danger boy is that yeah okay
okay okay yeah
why why would they not put that in the
show it's such like such great
production value if it doesn't add to
the storage oh
wow we got to see the mona lisa without
a [ __ ] ton of people
that that's different you're such an
uncultured swine
what's the [ __ ] that's in front of the
rich casey we're gonna go to the
versailles
messiah
yeah right shut that place down yeah
look at the price or not maybe she did
it on a weekday i don't think there is a
prize
she probably did the weekday yeah it's
not it's not a thai tourist
time i was like a thursday or something
it was like getting disneyland on a
monday night yeah
instead of like a hundred thousand
people it's like fifty thousand people
yeah normally
uh no that's pretty cool i'll show you
guys some pictures that's
freaking insane see that's sometimes
that's like there's like rich people
that you think are rich and there's just
like
what the [ __ ] is i don't even know you
could do that you can't do that even if
you have money like i know connie and
kim try to do it once or something like
for the whole thing
so it's like not only rich but also
connections
they gave her a key to keith by the way
what does that look like i have a
picture of it it's no it's like just
like an old school key so she's in town
she's like i gotta use the [ __ ] or i'll
be in the palace oversight
that's the only place i go in paris by
the way
why is she so connected like that
can't even say i don't even know wow wow
i mean her
her dad dealt with like arm like
armories pinks
like guys military stuff yeah during all
the war yeah
oh god they've been getting a surprise
and it's a trip to paris when do you
find out about the surprise are you on a
plane you don't know where you're going
yeah
when you have your boarding pass yeah
act like what would it be
no i i knew when i was like i have
boarding passes yeah a jets you don't
even know that's true
no no do you know what a boarding pass
is
[Laughter]
have you ever been through tsa do you
know what tsa is
yeah tsa she doesn't cheers preacher
guys
she she used to be one of us i think
she's like knows
because she remembered i have rich
amnesia right
oh right okay shaker casey shaker
you remember kevin what it's like to be
normal
when's the last time do you remember hot
dog a hot dog have you had one
hot dog yeah okay yeah okay we lost her
you mean truffle dog
oh no you know what's funny so like okay
you're
you know most of your friends on the
show they're all asian right and they're
hella rich
but i have a feeling that no matter how
rich an asian person gets
there's still things that they complain
about which is price yeah
is this true oh king king everything
he's like this is so expensive no no
it's not that it's like free free
he wants everything free oh [ __ ] so you
can afford everything but he wants a
discount it's like
oprah why is oprah like that loves
getting [ __ ] for free yeah it's a nice
little rush i think
i think no matter how much money you
have you get something for free yeah
that's true or you like discount a
little bit get a deal he loves it but
king loves giving back to charities and
doing a lot of charity work but
when we go to restaurants he's like
discount this guy
i get excited and then he gives him a
big tip obviously at the end but
so it actually balances out how much
he's paying more i think it's a game for
him
yeah yeah for sure he always over order
he's like you pay
that's great so like you made your
wealth through entrepreneurship right
and
for me i kind of feel like there is a
i don't want to say disconnect but like
there's a difference in culture
from kids that grew up rich versus like
people that
made their own money and then like yeah
so like when
i always feel like oh i'm reminded like
oh yeah like
this is the difference between us do you
get that
when you're around like these friends
for sure um
not so much with the cast of playing
empire because i think like
kane knows the value of dollar really
well like his parents really
raised him right um anna just in her
own world so like she's not even in
reality half a time she's in her own
world so it's a little bit different to
shut down the palace of herself that's
correct you can afford to not live in
reality if you're in yeah it's
anna's world while just living in it you
know um but i i have friends who are
trust me babies i just couldn't connect
with because
their vision was very narrow and how
they see the world is very different
yeah because it's like they grew up so
differently that it's hard to connect
with
people i guess yeah i have a friend
who's in his 50s he's still he's never
drove a car before
what so he's doing everyone driving he's
a driver he's a full-time driver because
the water bottle
is he ridiculous what kind of car does
he ride in then
like it's like he's a daily writer they
have different cars like rolls royce he
says in the back
you know but he has a full-time driver
is there a brand that we're all like
that's rich people [ __ ] and then rich
people are like
no yeah like there's there's like a
mercedes
like a corvette that's definitely not
rich yeah it's not rich people [ __ ]
exactly
there's nothing wrong with corvettes but
the new corvette looks sick it looks
really good i agree with you fake lamp
it looks like an american ferrari
but like is there anything like that we
all are like oh [ __ ] rolex and you guys
are like
i don't know um do you guys know how
much a bird can cost
what's a bird oh i heard they're like i
only hear it in like lyrics rappler you
have like 30
dollars or something there's different
levels like working back right like
twenty thousand
like minimum that's like this that's
that's like the least expensive right
something like that yeah what's the
level you do
so there's the leather one which is
about 15
20. oh [ __ ] and then there's the
himalaya which is over 100k
wow so and then you can't buy them
either you have to be invited to buy
wow have you been invited to buy one i
have a few
yeah i i don't have one
i don't have the himalaya i can't
justify that carrying a freaking hundred
thousand
good for you good for you i can't
justify that the himalay is it
is it made out of like i don't know
[ __ ] yama skin or whatever
yeah yeah
yeah what's himalayan about it i don't
know actually it's just call that
because it's the highest peaks
maybe we should probably google it made
in india see i'm not
educated have you ever been to a denny's
or a waffle house
what's your favorite video i hop what's
your order [ __ ]
prove it uh eggs and thank you she knows
about it
she knows what they sell knows the menu
try to get her but
she's good oh see she closed it but was
that 20 years ago
[Music]
you